it's not just a signal
that's a warning
aloha hey guys hey hey dc fans dc fans
this is going to blow you away come join
me join me jason momoa dc fandom
tomorrow it's all here for you the fans
see you there i promise you you won't
want to miss it
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
tomorrow is dc fandom and a lot of
people are really excited including
myself because we're going to be getting
a lot tomorrow when it comes down to the
batman black adam aquaman 2 and much
much more and ahead of dc fandom dc has
started to tease a lot of things
specifically concerning the batman today
they released two new posters and matt
reeves released a new picture of selena
kyle aka catwoman and yesterday they
released a tiny little teaser that had
some audio from the film which of course
i will be going over and if you want to
stay up to date on the things happening
with dc fandom be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out i'll be covering dc a lot more
from here on out but don't worry daily
marvel content is not going anywhere but
let's take a look at these two new the
batman posters because they are insanely
cool now one is just of batman himself
it's raining but the background is
entirely red including the symbol the
bat symbol on his chest that is also red
now we know that this is going to be
batman during year two it's going to be
the start of batman his origin so this
batman's going to be figuring a lot out
still and as we've seen from the teaser
trailer he's going to be a little bit
more brutal than we're used to and i
think this red background kind of
symbolizes that and of course the death
of his parents as well now then we have
another poster of the riddler he is
holding a note and it says to the batman
and of course in this note it's going to
have a riddle that's what he does he's
the riddler but apparently this riddler
is going to be different than anything
that we've seen in the past it's said
that he's not going to be a villain per
se but he is going to be a huge
antagonist which obviously it's the
riddler now of course everybody is
really waiting for the new the batman
trailer that is going to be coming
tomorrow at dc fandom this is confirmed
they released the teaser at last year's
dc fandom and now a year later we are
getting the full official trailer and
apparently according to some people who
have seen the trailer already and
according to some people who actually
saw some footage a couple of months ago
this trailer is going to be absolutely
insane and blow our minds in fact people
are saying that it's going to break the
internet now i'm super pumped for this
because ultimately batman is one of my
all-time favorite superheroes and i
think the cast is going to do an amazing
job today matt reeves released an
exclusive photo of zoe kravitz as selena
kyle aka catwoman and i'm really excited
to see the relationship between her and
robert pattinson's batman because
apparently that is phenomenal as well
now we're not only going to get the
batman trailer tomorrow we're also going
to be getting a lot for other dc
projects that they have coming up
specifically black adam and aquaman 2.
today dc fandom released a tiny little
teaser saying that you don't want to
miss out on tomorrow and jason mamoa was
there promoting dc fandom and aquaman 2
and the rock was also there saying that
you don't want to miss out in fact he
said that this is going to blow you away
and we have yet to get an official
teaser trailer for black adam so fingers
crossed that we actually get it tomorrow
at dc fandom and we'll probably get
somewhat of a first look at aquaman as
well and a lot of other really cool
projects that dc is working on right now
so don't miss out on dc fandom tomorrow
i will also be covering it doing a
couple of videos tomorrow about the
batman and other news that we see so if
you want to stay up to date don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof